let's hear from the most important
people in the audience and those are the
viewers and the listeners we'll take
some calls now from our Discord at
davidpackman.com Discord
starting with I hope I pronounced this
correctly Rahman from Minneapolis
welcome did I did I pronounce that okay
yes you did David how are you doing I'm
doing well
good a long time viewer have been
watching your show since high school wow
thank you
my question is um with everything that's
been going on the last two years do you
believe the Republican party is trying
to reinstitute a 21st century version of
Jim Crow
well most of them don't even know what
that is so I would say not conscious I
don't think they're using Jim Crow as a
model
but I do think that they are reacting
with a lot of the same instincts where
as they're increasingly frustrated that
the law doesn't allow them to do certain
things they want to do they're trying to
find ways around it to achieve
essentially the same outcomes if that
makes sense and that includes when it
comes to immigration policy this
includes with when it comes to
educational policy and you know this
idea of get rid of the Department of
Education different things like that the
impact of a lot of those things would be
similar to the impact of of uh some of
the things in place during the Jim Crow
era so in that sense I would say yeah to
some degree
yeah because when you see when you look
at back in the history books and you you
could see the parallels uh with with
people going against the LGBT community
going with the voter restriction yep the
anti-abortion laws when you look at
Illinois what happened with Mary Miller
and she she was ABS she was saying this
is a victory for white life yeah that's
the the that was quoted language
I agree with you 100 100 and really all
we can do is try to ensure that the
people who want to do this stuff don't
get into positions of power sadly many
of them are already in positions of
power but at every opportunity to vote
let's try to prevent more of them from
being voted in
okay that was my only question thank you
for taking my call David all right thank
you Rockman from Minneapolis very much
appreciate the call